okay so listen we're this next story not
something that I already suspected I
wouldn't even be bringing it up but as
many of you know I have long suspected
that Donald Trump from my completely
amateur unsophisticated point of view
sometimes seems to be on uppers and
sometimes seems to be clearly coming
down from uppers there are pictures now
which appear to show boxes and boxes of
sudafed and upper at Donald Trump's desk
we're going to get to all of the details
there is the upper Trump I've mentioned
before that's the one that is speaking
quickly sweating often sniffing a lot
and then there's the other Trump the
slow slurring god bless the United
States of America the depressed looking
and sounding Trump and it's all very
weird and this goes back to that bizarre
tweet that Donald Trump sent during his
2016 campaign where he proclaimed that
he loves Hispanics while eating a taco
bowl from the Trump Tower Grill remember
this tweet and picture happy Cinco de
Mayo the best taco bowls are made in
Trump Tower Grill I love Hispanics and
the really fascinating thing here is not
actually Trump's taco Bowl but it's
what's in the drawer just to Donald
Trump's left and behind him over his
left shoulder short sort of there's an
open drawer which Twitter user Jay
railing points out is filled with boxes
of sudafed quote in 2016 Trump posted a
photo of himself that gay will gave away
more than he intended an open desk
drawer revealed box after box of sudafed
piled on top of one another and when you
look closely at that picture you do see
what looked like at least four boxes of
sudafed now Jay railing makes a few
other claims in his tweet thread I've
tried to research them and they are even
more interesting the first one for
example is that although the photo was
taken in New York the boxes include a
type that is only sold in the UK with a
different box and distinctive
ingredients not
in the US I went on cbs.com and indeed
that version of sudafed is not sold in
the United States currently they sell
others but not that one same thing at
Walgreens so it seems that at least
currently this sudafed is not even
available in the United States now as we
know Trump often seems overly alert and
has notably dilated pupils to symptoms
of taking exactly this now the thing is
this is not a new allegation
Nowell casler is in new york city
comedian who worked on trump's show The
Apprentice and has said many times
Trump was snorting adderall and eating
sudafed quote Trump snorted adderall all
through the day on apprentice he also
ate UK sudafed like candy but at night
and at parties he switched to cocaine
and high-end methamphetamine that was
hand-delivered by bikers the point is he
was always high that hasn't changed
and of course if you go back to the
video of Trump's debates with Hillary
Clinton there was that constant sniffing
that also raised questions about Trump's
drug use remember this
[Music]
so that's difficult to listen to I
apologize I'm just being thorough here
and again often extremely dilated pupils
that just don't seem to make sense for
the amount of light that is in the room
where the pictures are often taken so am
i saying this to make fun of Trump no he
may well have a problem but it is to
point out that upper Trump and downer
Trump have been visibly very different
from the beginning and I can only
imagine that if someone has access to
nuclear weapons and is involved in
diplomatic conversations with world
leaders at the highest level this is not
what you want you don't want upper and
downer version of the world leader that
can launch nuclear weapons make or break
alliances and relationships slap tariffs
that destroy you know hundreds of
thousands of workers businesses this is
not a guy that's not a position rather
where you want a guy that has an upper
version and a downer version I want to
hear from you about this what do you
make of this when I've brought up the
Trump up or down or stuff in the past I
get substance abuse professionals who
email me and they say David don't use my
name I it would not be appropriate for
my name to be publicly attached to this
but I've been noticing the exact same
thing as you and I think you're exactly
spot-on let me know what you think about
this the pictures the sniffing the
dilated pupils the entire thing I do
want to hear from you about it I have
video for you today of a longtime trump
brown-nosing sycophant one of the real
sick fox news Trump defenders realizing
on live television that Trump is
absolutely clueless and has no idea what
he's doing and you can actually see him
become more and more enraged
despite being someone who is almost
exclusively wrong on policy I'm talking
of course of Brian Kilmeade
the one that some people think is the
dumb one
on Fox & Friends but it may not actually
be the case and of course there is a lot
of competition for that role that
designation on Fox & Friends
we've been talking about Donald Trump's
recent decision to pull back troops in
northern Syria to allow Turkey to run a
military operation along with Donald
Trump's threat to destroy and obliterate
Turkey's economy if they do anything
Donald Trump doesn't like combined with
within hours turkey bombing Kurdish
forces in northern Syria we've already
talked about all of that Brian Kilmeade
came up with one of the reasons why
Donald Trump's actions are concerning
which is yes they endanger the Kurds in
northern Syria which happens to be a
concern that a lot of people share it's
Noam Chomsky who shares that concern
it's me it's some Republicans as well
and you can just tell that Brian
Kilmeade is disgusted with Trump in this
video and you can also tell when you go
to the wide shot or I think it's a wide
shot the entire time when you see Steve
deucey deucey I always have to be
careful to pronounce it correctly when
you see co-hosts Steve Doocy and I
believe it's Ainsley Earhardt they don't
want anything to do with this they are
still fully on the sucking up to trump
train and what's funny is that brian
kilmeade
if you watch him deliver any political
opinion
he always has like a slightly confused
expression on his face
even if he's making a roundabout point
that has some element of truth which he
does in this case he always seems like
one microsecond away from completely
losing the thread and becoming totally
in canarian coherent and meanwhile Steve
Doocy
looks visibly uncomfortable with what
kill me to saying Ainsley Earhardt seems
to want no part in the conversation one
way or another take a look at this this
what a disaster I mean the president's
statement through Stephanie Grisham is
you know we defeated the the caliphate
the café's destroyed we would not have
done that without the Kurds who did all
of our fighting while our guys the
reason why our casualties were so low is
because Kurds did all the fighting now
we're saying ok Turks go wipe them out
or force them out what kind of message
is that to the next ally that wants to
side with us
meanwhile we're taking Sunni prisoners
and giving him to Sunni Turkey who's
been nothing but irresponsible though
technically a NATO ally a disaster a
series of events I hope the president
will rethink this I think the
president's doing exactly what he's
wants to because he has made from the
get-go very clear to release Isis
fighters campaign promise to end and you
know man Steve Doocy is a guy to play
off of his just tough right I mean he
sounds like a little kid he's a 62 year
old man but he sounds like a kid well I
think Trump is just doing what he wants
to so yeah and then that riles up
Kilmeade even more as we continue that's
a campaign promise no I and in the
people that got the Caliphate destroyed
I think when people find out that
somebody else is willing to take over
the fight against Isis they're gonna be
okay was taking it well
Turkey's second fight Isis we have given
turkey permission to do that and to take
and the quote was Turkey will now be
responsible for all Isis fighters they
kill de and wipe out the Kurds are you
kidding me again we're banning our most
loyal allies who did all our fighters
all we did is arm them and they did all
the work and now we say good luck good
luck surviving well it looks like that's
the attack the White House and the
president's gonna take we're gonna have
as bad as Brian Kilmeade political
analysis is even though he hits on
something here of course Steve Ducey's
dumb comments are just too much but what
good luck surviving Brian that's the
tactic the White House is taking so
there there are these tiny little sort
of hairline cracks that are forming in
the echo chamber of Fox News by mere
coincidence because kilmeade wants
soldiers in Syria do you think that
after a segment like this when they go
to commercial or after they're done
filming do you think they go to the
break room stand around the water cooler
and they say Brian what was that all
about that was weird what was what what
went on there and what you have is okay
Brian Kilmeade like a clock that doesn't
move it ends up being right twice a day
and Brian Kilmeade has stumbled upon
what is at least a partially correct
and it just seems completely out of
place on fox news now that that's over
Fox News can resume the self eating by
the way which is actually the bigger
media story that I think we should be
talking about I've been preparing you
for this for about a year now I think
it's been about a year it's certainly
dating back to last May if not earlier
when we start looking at the possible
separation of Trump and Fox of Trump and
Republicans you have to understand that
there is much more to it than simply
will Fox support Trump in the 2020
reelection campaign we are starting to
see political disagreements that are
becoming more than just public they are
starting to actually affect the way that
politics is happening behind the scenes
in Washington DC you're starting to see
Moscow Mitch separate from Trump a
little bit more than he has in the past
over this Syria issue you're starting to
see Looney Lindsey Looney Lindsey Graham
start to distance himself from Trump a
little bit even though he was like the
greatest Trump brown-noser out there for
a very long period of time but it's not
just forward progress because then Trump
will backpedal and he'll pull some
people back in but then it'll happen
again and we'll see what ultimately
happens I don't know if you said to me
today David take a position by November
of 2020 will Trump and Fox still have
this marriage made not in heaven but you
know with a prenup and under duress
which is I guess the way most of Donald
Trump's relationships seem to develop
will we still have that in November of
2020 or will we have seen a total
separation between Trump and Fox News
and if so that raises a whole host of
additional questions will Trump have
moved over to oen one America News
Network which I've been predicting for a
while and Trump is started to promote a
little bit around the edges will we see
those right-wing media outlets that
abandoned Trump actively promote an
alternative will they promote a Democrat
I don't think so will they promote a
primary challenge to trump or voting
third party I don't know but these are
some of the interesting questions that
I look forward to seeing answered as the
campaign continues to develop let me
know what you think will ultimately
happen let me know what you make by the
way of Brian Kilmeade staking out this
position wish again it's not unique to
kill me there are lots of Republicans
who want troops in Syria for different
reasons the Kurd the danger to the Kurds
specifically though is not always the
one that you hear Donald Trump has
suffered a major loss and we've taken
one giant step towards seeing Donald
Trump's tax returns and Donald Trump is
furious and he has ordered he has been
ordered to turn over eight years of his
and his company's tax returns and I'll
explain the entire trajectory to you
I've told you before the Manhattan
district attorney is investigating
Donald Trump's company for criminality
and requested a bunch of personal and
corporate tax returns Trump immediately
sued to stop the release of those taxes
a federal judge has now dismissed the
lawsuit meaning that unless Donald Trump
can come up with some new reason to
block the release of those returns to
the Manhattan da he is going to have to
provide them or will he right because
what I mean is the consequences for
Trump so far for just not doing what
he's told when it comes to providing
documents have been zero but it is a
step a step in the right direction the
argument that Donald Trump made to
prevent the release of these tax returns
was that as president he is immune not
just from criminal prosecution which of
course he believes but that's a broader
question but that he is immune also from
even being criminally investigated
period now judge Victor Marrero Oh
Hispanic guy Trump might lose it anyway
Victor Marrero says that that's not
gonna fly rejected the argument all
together and says Trump's gotta provide
the tax returns and in the immediate
hours that followed Donald Trump's
lawyers appealed it and the US Circuit
Court has granted Donald Trump a stay
saying okay if you're appealing it we
will delay forcing Trump to provide
those tax returns but this is now one
bullet that's been fired by Trump and
the bullet has missed Trump of course
furious blaming radical left Democrats
on Twitter saying quote the radical left
Democrats capital R capital L naturally
have failed on all fronts so now they
are pushing local New York city and
state Democrat prosecutors to go get
President Trump a thing like this has
never happened to any president before
not even close so what's going to happen
here I'm gonna give you like the remote
the realist assessment of what I think
is going to go down I believe that
Donald Trump will use every single
option that he can he will exhaust every
crazy notion to avoid having to provide
these tax returns and meanwhile he will
further the witch-hunt narrative like he
did on Russia like he's doing on Ukraine
there's a good chance it's not a hundred
percent but there's a good chance that
at some point a judge will say listen
legally you've got to provide your tax
returns to investigators they will then
put out just like the bar letter just
like the truncated memo about the
Ukraine phone call they will put out
some completely edited tax returns that
he will claim are complete records and
then investigators and Democrats will
correctly say no but this is BS these
are completely incomplete and then Trump
will say look I finally give them to you
and you still don't like them and before
you know it it'll be the twenty twenty
election and Donald Trump will win
re-election that that's a combination of
realistic and sort of cynical assessment
which I do happen to think is actually
the most likely assessment of what's
going to go on here and in the end we
will get back to what is in Trump's
taxes that he is so desperately and for
so many years fought tooth and nail to
prevent their release and the answer is
several things speculation but if we
wonder given what we know about Trump
given what we know about Trump's ego
given what we know about from shady
business connections to use a very light
term that is probably too understated we
could learn from Trump's taxes
that he is not nearly as wealthy as he
claims we could learn from Trump's taxes
I mean it's almost guaranteed that he
inflates the values of assets to get
loans and that those assets actually
aren't worth that much and on the taxes
he may even understate the values of
those assets we may learn the names of
the shell companies and all sorts of
forensic accounting leads for more
things to look into we could learn about
various types of fraud because what is
on Trump's taxes may not be in line with
other financial disclosures and loan
applications and things that Donald
Trump has previously disclosed there are
many possibilities here but let me say
this because apparently this is totally
legal and totally cool to say now
Kurdish hackers if you're listening
Icelandic hackers whoever if you're
listening if you were to find Donald
Trump's taxes I believe the media would
greatly reward you Trump said it about
Hillary's emails to Russia can't be
anything wrong with me saying it to
Kurdish hackers and Icelandic hackers
about Donald Trump's taxes just saying
I'm guessing the media would greatly
reward you welcome to the show I am back
from my emergency appendectomy which I
will talk about more a little bit later
but let's get into the news if you
somehow believed that the Ukraine
whistleblower is just a total liar or a
plant someone that can't be trusted
even though Donald Trump has already
confirmed a whole bunch of what the
whistleblower said there is now a second
whistleblower that is in the process of
coming forward in a world where Donald
Trump wants us to think everything is
fine we have yet another set of
blockbuster allegations potentially
coming forward from another
whistleblower related to Ukraine and
understand that the second whistleblower
is also an intelligence official and has
as far as we know right now first-hand
knowledge of the Ukraine Fiasco
involving Donald Trump now how far we've
fallen that in the past we'd say oh a
whistleblower from inside the Intel
community this is some
we should take seriously in the Trump
era one of the most maligned areas has
been the intelligence community where
the president has successfully primed
his defenders not to believe anything we
hear from the intelligence community now
there's an important point to make here
before we continue the American
intelligence community has done many bad
things in the past and mostly they have
been things Republicans have liked
importantly but that's an aside right
now this is not about defending the
Intel community as a political apparatus
lots of right-wingers even some on the
Left say we should hate the Intel
community because it's been terrible for
decades and when you allow the
intelligence community some kind of
elevated status to tell us who is
behaving okay and who is not you are
essentially giving over political policy
to spies and that's not something we
want to do now there are lots of that
that makes sense there are many
political disagreements to be had with
the intelligence community's actions in
the past CIA and Latin America I mean I
don't even need to do the list but this
is about attacking the credibility of
individuals and the work that they do
which is mostly motivated by wanting to
do the right thing at the individual
level which gets us back to her story
because there may even be more than two
whistleblowers at this point check this
out this is a tweet from Andrew bacause
who represents whistleblowers from the
intelligence community who said
intelligence community whistleblower
update I can confirm that my firm and my
team represent multiple whistleblowers
in connection to the underlying August
12 2019 disclosure to the intelligence
community Inspector General no further
comment at this time
multiple whistleblowers could be - could
be more now the president immediately
writing this off as the actions of the
deep State the President of the United
States is no longer even pretending to
be anything other than a blatant
conspiracy theorist tweeting quote the
first
so-called secondhand information
whistleblower got my phone conversation
almost completely wrong not true by the
way
so now word is they are going to the
bench and another whistleblower is
coming in from the deep state also with
second-hand info meet with shifty keep
them coming now Trump mentions shifty
which is his nickname for Adam Schiff
head of the House Intelligence Committee
and this is the new attack strategy from
Donald Trump the first strategy was the
deny deny deny that didn't work then the
strategy became well say that there was
nothing wrong that happened even though
you did talk about Joe Biden and most of
the material details that we got are
actually accurate even by your own
admission say everything was fine now
it's well they are all left-wing
Democratic deep state plants controlled
by Adam Schiff and Trump's attorney Rudy
Giuliani who himself by the way should
be a target of these investigations
tweeting very much on the same page
quote surprise Democrat lawyer has other
secret sources swamp media will
corruptly fail to point out it means
nothing now that conversation is public
no money no quid pro quo
unlike Biden helping son make millions
from Ukrainian crook orchestrated dem
campaign like Cavanaugh listen these
people are not well ok these are truly
sick people and we can do political
analyses up and down every single day
but the political analyses fall short
because in a sense a political analysis
assumes that we are dealing with well
people which we are not we are now going
to get a chance to see just how blind
and bamboozled Donald Trump supporters
are and here's the big story it started
with one whistleblower on Ukraine one on
the IRS which you may not even have
heard about we now have a second one on
Ukraine all within two weeks just
imagine how many pent-up potential
whistleblowers there are who have seen
in cred
illegal things the trumpets are doubling
down on this is a democratic hit job
it's all fake and we showed you the
transcript of course the transcript is
only a portion of the call and is
already terrible for them and was
already reportedly a precondition of
Ukraine investigating Biden and
promising this deliverable so what the
trumpets have as their strongest defense
is to pretend that the transcript is
exculpatory when in fact it is a damning
piece of evidence and once again imagine
what we will know in just another week
okay support for the impeachment and
removal of Donald Trump has exploded and
support for the impeachment inquiry has
nearly tripled even among Republicans
over the last couple of weeks this is
not good news for Donald Trump Donald
Trump has been touting these
cartoonishly high approval ratings from
Republicans sometimes trumple tweet
Republican 95% support thank you and
maybe that's true in some poll I mean I
haven't seen it maybe Rasmussen has
Trump at ninety five percent approval
among Republicans that's not the data
that I've been seeing most of the polls
I've looked at have Trump's Republican
approval somewhere between the high 70s
and around 80 and what that means is
that there are one out of five
Republicans that do not approve of the
job that Donald Trump is doing this gets
us to more specifically assessing
support for the impeachment of the
president in the first week that week
between the start of the Ukraine Fiasco
going public and the few days after the
impeachment inquiry was announced
support for impeaching and removing
Trump went from 36% to 43% that was an
increase of about 20 percent another
week has gone by and support has
increased even more the questions in
this latest data are a little bit
different but most importantly support
for the impeachment inquiry has exploded
among all Democrats Republicans and
independents and it is growing in pair
across party lines this is very
important and it's important because
Donald Trump needs that Republican
electorate to win re-election in 2020
so first 49% in a Washington Post Shar
school poll want the house to call for
the removal of Donald Trump 49% of
Americans 58 percent of Americans say
that the impeachment inquiry is correct
that it is the right thing to do but
maybe the single most notable number to
come out of this new poll is that the
move towards impeachment has happened
across party lines Democratic support
for the inquiry is up 25 points
independent support for the inquiry is
up 20 points and Republican support for
the inquiry is up 21 points thirty
percent of Republicans now support the
impeachment inquiry that Democrats are
trying to carry out but does this matter
right I mean why do we care in the end
if three out of ten Republicans support
the inquiry because a Republican Senate
is very unlikely to vote to convict the
reason we care is that the whole point
of this is to get people not to vote for
Trump in 2020 and I'm using very precise
language there now I know that there are
some people in my audience holding out
hope that the impeachment inquiry could
lead to Donald Trump's removal because
Republicans in the Senate will vote to
convict I see it as incredibly unlikely
but anything is possible the much more
realistic outcome is that the success of
the impeachment inquiry depends on
influencing public opinion when we look
at public opinion you see that in two
weeks in two weeks Republican support
for the impeachment inquiry has
effectively tripled from around 10
percent 11 12 maybe it was to 30 percent
this does not bode well for Donald Trump
now a reasonably skeptical observer of
this would ask the question if you're a
Republican and you support the inquiry
does that mean you're going to vote for
a Democrat in November of 2020 and
that's a very good question to ask and
the answer is of course not
you are not necessarily or even likely
to vote for a Democrat in November of
2020 if you are a Republican who merely
thinks that the inquiry is warranted but
you might stay home and that alone could
be good enough to pull Trump out of the
White House assuming that we on the Left
get our base out as well in the last two
weeks we've seen Republican impeachment
inquiry support triple we have seen
triple three we've seen prominent
Republicans start to turn on Trump we've
seen loony Lindsey Graham and Moscow
Mitch McConnell albeit not over the
Ukraine stuff but over the serious stuff
start to sort of part ways with Donald
Trump to some degree we are seeing the
right-wing media like Fox News embroiled
in what I described earlier this week or
last week as an internal cannibalistic
battle over whether or not they will be
on the Trump train in 2020 and meanwhile
Trump has gone out after courting
Ukraine in a private phone call and
courted the Chinese for political dirt
on Joe Biden after the impeachment
inquiry was launched just imagine when
you look at what has taken place over
the last two weeks just imagine what
could happen between today and the next
democratic debate which is in a week
unprecedented circumstances Donald Trump
drawing a line in the sand saying he
will not participate in the impeachment
inquiry whose support has now tripled
tripled among Republicans stunning stuff
I want to hear from you what do you
think is going to be the next shoe to
drop
make sure you are commenting if you're
watching on YouTube make sure to send me
a tweet on Twitter at D Pakman and while
you're there
follow the david pakman show on twitter
at david pakman show we'll take a quick
break and be back right after this
a major former Trump staffer is now
predicting that Donald Trump will
ultimately resign the presidency of the
United States and I'm going to have her
comments for you in a moment but listen
we've talked about this before
III every time I say this I get a few
angry emails I don't think Trump is
going to be removed by impeachment
I just don't think it's going to happen
I don't think Donald Trump is going to
resign but I do believe that if Donald
Trump started to seriously believe that
he was at risk of being removed and
possibly facing criminal prosecution I
think that is the one scenario under
which he might resign the former vice
president of the Trump Organization
Barbara rests is saying exactly this
that Trump is acting just the way he
used to act at the Trump Organization
the paranoia the anger flying off the
handle and that he might resign
specifically to save face she said this
to CNN check it out and when Kellyanne
Conway's husband says he's unfit for
office do you agree with that assessment
I do yes but I thought that when he was
running and not not for necessarily the
mental reason said they talked about but
because he didn't have the experience
and you know lots of different things so
how do you see this ending now does it
end at the ballot box in a year does he
make it to a second term does he resign
as a result of impeachment what do you
think you know it's funny I people ask
me that and I'm thinking you know it's
hard to say my opinion on national TV
because I could very well be wrong but
let me let me tell you what I thought I
mean I think that he does a lot of
things to save face and I could give you
examples we all have time but I mean
there are some things that you know he
can't control and he's now at the point
where he can't control this he can't do
anything about this it would be very
very very bad for him to be impeached
impeached
I don't know that he'd be found guilty
but I don't think he wants to be in
peace I think yeah I think that's what
this panic is about and my gut tells me
he'll leave office he'll resign or make
some kind of a deal even depending on
what comes out the deal thing is a
bigger and bigger part of this once
again I don't believe that this is
heading to an impeachment conviction
some in my audience disagree with me but
as soon as that becomes a reality if it
ever does we immediately start getting
into does Trump pull pens down with him
does Trump set mike pence up to pardon
him if he pre M
the resins does he pull pants down but
make a deal for Pence's replacement with
someone that will pardon him and then
there's also a completely opposite
assessment of all of this which some
people are making which is even though
Trump doesn't like the idea of articles
of impeachment there is a position to be
staked out which i think is a reasonable
one that a failed impeachment attempt or
even an inquiry that doesn't go well
could re-energize Donald Trump's base it
could get some Republicans who are sort
of lukewarm on Trump to just bite the
bullet and vote for the guy that is not
a crazy prediction about how this could
go now as far as how you know the
Barbara res thing goes of course right
away trumpets are attacking her she's
clearly not clued in to what Trump would
do she just wants to malign Trump she
doesn't really know Trump I even saw
some comments online saying Trump would
never sleep with this woman is that like
even at issue here I didn't think that
that was on the table anyway this is not
a particularly difficult to believe
assessment I believe that Donald Trump
will do anything he can to not only
avoid impeachment but to avoid
resignation but if it really came down
to it if the rubber really started
meeting the road Trump might resign to
avoid an impeachment conviction Nixon
did it it's not a shocking thing to
think might happen if it went that way
but it's nice to see that the trumpets
immediately identify personal attacks
against a woman as the way to defend
Donald Trump against any critical
statement against their Dear Leader it
completely predictable in every way
Barbara rest let me know what you think
I basically agree with her I think where
I disagree with Barbara rest is I don't
believe this scenario will come to pass
I do agree that to save face a cornered
trump who believes he will be removed by
impeachment would resign I just don't
believe it's going to get to that point
let me know what you think make sure you
are following the show on twitch at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman live
streams will be resuming soon quick
break back after this with much more it
is endlessly fascinating what is going
on with Mike Pence over the last 10
or so we learned from the Washington
Post that it wasn't merely Mike Pompeo
Trump's Secretary of State who was on
that now infamous phone call between
Donald Trump and the Ukrainian president
vice president Mike Pence was also on
the call putting him fully into the fray
and right away / NBC News vice president
Mike Pence received a letter from House
Democrats on Friday demanding that he
turn over documents related to the
president's dealings with Ukraine mother
as he refers to her is not going to like
this one bit that we can be sure of now
before we dig into what we know there
are two views on this one view is Pence
is genuinely as much a part of the
rampant criminality as his Trump he's
complicit he's involved he's a major
player that's view number one the other
view is well Pence is sort of involved
but really it's Trump who's going to
make sure to take pence down with him if
he goes down simply because that's the
kind of person that Donald Trump is and
one reason that one might start to think
that maybe Trump is going to make sure
to take pence down is that he actually
said at that September 25 press
conference at the UN he said Mike
Pence's conversations with Ukraine
out of the blue he said should also be
looked into you can look at those
they're perfect but of course no one was
talking about them they're getting hit
hard on this witch-hunt because when
they look at the information it's a joke
impeachment for that I think you should
ask for VP Pence's conversation because
he had a couple of conversations oh so I
could take a lot of time they were all
perfect and when you see little Adam
Schiff go out and lie and lie and stand
it that my smart guy by the way so the
question is is this another unforced
error by Donald Trump or is Donald Trump
slowly but surely starting to pull Mike
Pence into this thing deliberately and
then when you look at it Trump is
actually right Mike Pence is in way over
his head on this entire thing it's
becoming the fort reasons for
lack of a better term Trump pens Pompeo
and we'll see who gets that fourth spot
in the band before we know what I'm sure
Pence's team is saying oh yeah well
pence was strongly pressing the
Ukrainians to investigate corruption but
he had no idea that it was because Trump
wanted Biden smeared it's already
getting weird when you start to see
spokespeople for the President and
vice-president starting to have
implicitly conflicting points of view if
not direct conflict at this point in
time and in the end we get to this
question are we better off with pence or
are we worse off with pence could pence
be removed along with Donald Trump but
there's really only one answer
impeachment won't remove either of them
it will be up to us in November of 2020
more and more people are angry with me
saying David don't write off removing
Trump senators might vote to remove him
I'm not writing it off but I'm writing
it off as a strategy to win because it's
both unlikely and it's out of our
control you can come up with all sorts
of scenarios once you pull Penson will
impeach Trump but not pence allow pence
to resign so that a new VP can be
confirmed before Trump's removal who
then becomes president of the United
States you can go through all of these
scenarios the two most likely realities
are Pence is almost as big a player here
as is Donald Trump and neither is going
to be removed by impeachment it's not
impossible but it's unlikely to happen
and it's not something we can strategize
around so it is up to us to vote in
November of 2020 and make sure that
these people are removed if you disagree
with me on the strategy let me know I
understand people who are saying I
shouldn't already have as a foregone
conclusion that nothing will go anywhere
with impeachment okay as a strategy the
focus needs to be voting them out and
using any information that we can to
expose the corrupt and ridiculous nature
of what they've done in order to get
more people interested in voting in
November of 2020 i'm on instagram at
david pakman the show is on instagram at
david pakman show quick
Raik back after this okay so today I am
going to show you an absolutely
outrageous and baseless Donald Trump
line but I'm gonna do something else
I'm gonna show you the genesis of the
lie I'm gonna show you the evolution of
the lie how it becomes more and more
dishonest over time and we in a sense to
quote Donald Trump we're going to look
at the oranges of this lie or as I like
to call them the origins of this lie so
Donald Trump spoke yesterday I believe
it was maybe it was late on Monday and
it was complete diarrhea of the mouth I
mean just endless lie after lie after
lie I'll give you the most sort of
cartoonish lie first which we'll be
focusing on which is that when Donald
Trump became president the military was
out of ammunition I know that may come
as a surprise to many of you in the
audience who are aware of how much money
we spend on the military but Trump's
claim is the military had no ammunition
when he became president but he fixed
that take a look at this i we all
together you we defeated and took over
100 percent of the Isis Caliphate
everybody said that was going to be an
impossible thing to do I did it and I
did it quickly because we have a great
military now when I took over a military
we didn't have ammunition I was told by
a top general maybe the top of them all
sir I'm sorry sir we don't have
ammunition I said I'll never let another
president have that happen to him or her
we didn't have ammunition now we've
captured Isis we've done what we've done
we had 50 soldiers in the area you're
talking about by the way no one said it
would be impossible to defeat Isis that
that's like another lie when the when
the Obama administration was getting
ready to exit I said many many times and
so did others that we are sort of on a
trajectory for at least with regard to
its territory the Caliphate is something
like the call it of Isis we are heading
towards the destruction of that the
question will be how do we deal with
radicalized cells that are disconnected
but whether it was Hillary or Trump what
Trump is talking about the elimination
of the Caliphate was likely to happen
either way I said it many people said it
but Trump's
as we had no ammunition when he became
president he fixed it and now lo and
behold we have captured Isis we'll get
back to that that's the lie I will show
you the evolution of but a few other
choice lies by Donald Trump from this
very strange speech Donald Trump
claiming of course with no evidence that
his poll numbers are up 17 points in the
last three days now when he says his
poll numbers does he mean hypothetical
2020 polling does he mean approval
polling we never know and of course the
reason we never know is because it is
made-up he has nothing to back this up
it's obviously untrue this is a scam and
the people of wires to it and that's why
my polls weren't up I think they said 17
points in the last two or three days
I've never had that one yes so no I mean
that just it didn't happen and then here
is Donald Trump saying total falsehoods
about Adam Schiff these are even less
coherent like these are it's more
difficult to even understand what
allegations Trump is making here but
they're all very much untrue take a look
Adam Schiff should be investigated for
what he did he took to the Great Chamber
Congress and he made a speech and his
speech was a fraud everything he said
was a fraud
he went out as though I wrote it he
defrauded the American people he
defrauded Congress he defrauded himself
and his family he made a speech as with
a horrible speech I said what does this
gut what's going on here
I think he's having some kind of a
breakdown because he got up and made a
speech that bore no relationship to what
the conversation was you can tell Trump
is kind of making it up as he goes along
and none of that stuff is true so let's
go back now to the ammunition claim
let's look at the oranges of this lie
where did Donald Trump's lie that the
military was out of ammunition
until Trump fixed it come from to begin
with this is the genesis of that lie the
evolution of the bogus story I think
you'll find this interesting so of
course it's not true that the Year Trump
became president the
military was out of ammunition in 2016
the u.s. spent more than six hundred
billion dollars on the military much of
that went to ammunition we had plenty of
ammunition already although it is true
that Barack Obama had slightly trimmed
the amount of military spending in some
areas okay
so Donald Trump's story started with way
back then when I met with general mattis
he came to me and he said we are low on
ammo now we don't even know if that's
true right it's possible that it's
totally made-up it's possible that
mattis went to trump and said listen we
are behind on the accumulation of a
certain type of ordnance it may not even
have been again if it's true it may not
even have been because Barack Obama
wasn't spending enough money it may have
been a supply issue it could have been
who knows right but it started with
mattis cam to me and said we are low on
ammo Trump has then exploded the
military budget so it's probably true
that Donald Trump has spent a lot more
money on ammunition Trump took that
story which may have a kernel of truth
in it or it may not like we don't even
know and then expanded the lie to say
well mattis said we have low /no
ammunition okay that was he modify
always has to go to the next step here's
Trump expanding it - it wasn't just low
it was low / no ammunition for the first
time today a general came into my office
and my first few weeks you remember was
a little dangerous out there
President Obama left us with a few
beauties right
and I said to this general you better be
prepared because this is looking like it
could really be conflict and he looked
at me and he goes sir we have very
little ammunition I said say it again
and I want to tell you the words very
little he didn't use because it was less
than that and I said I never want to see
a president in a position like that well
we may have conflict and a general looks
at him and said we have very little / no
ammunition I never want a President of
the United States to be in that position
okay so mattis supposedly saying we are
low we don't even know if that's true
becomes mattis said we are low / out of
ammunition okay this is the first
evolution of this lie then four days
later Donald Trump upgrades to we had no
ammunition at all I've rebuilt the
military we've Scott and I were talking
about that we spend one and a half
trillion dollars when I came in our
military was depleted frankly we didn't
have ammunition okay but our military
was in very bad shape and then now in
about a one month period it all becomes
we had no ammo and I fixed it
I got us ammo and because of that I was
able to defeat the Caliphate of Isis in
the Middle East when again the colonel
of possible truth is maybe mattis said
we were low possibly about some
particular kind of ammunition unclear if
it's because of anything Barack Obama
had done right could have been a supply
issue could have been anything and that
possible kernel of truth becomes Trump
endlessly repeating that we had no
ammunition and he got us a munition and
that's the ammunition that was ribeye
the way ammunition right I mean like
what an unsophisticated term to even be
using that is the ammunition that got us
the defeat of the Caliphate of Isis in
the Middle East thanks to the great lord
and savior donald trump the genesis of a
lie
okay understand how it works these
people will stop at nothing
he will say anything it doesn't matter
whether it has a grain of truth a kernel
of truth or not
question for you do you believe that
Donald Trump has convinced himself that
the latest most extreme version of the
story is true or do you think that Trump
knows that he is exaggerating this story
which possibly is not based in any
actual reality let me know i'm on
instagram at D Pakman the show is on
Instagram at David Pakman show